[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Well, thank
you for joining us today.
JEREMY PIVEN: Absolutely.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: We're excited to
have you for "Talks at Google."
And we're here to talk
about "Wisdom of the Crowd."
So could you tell us a little
bit about who each of you play?
JEREMY PIVEN: We waited all
that time for you to say that?
My 10-year-old niece Pearl
could have done that.
SPEAKER 1: You want to go with
the hard-hitting questions?
JEREMY PIVEN: No.
We'll do the heavy
lifting, and here we are.
I play Jeffrey Tanner,
who is a tech innovator.
And not unlike Steve Jobs,
we are introduced to him when
he's addressing
[? All Sourcer, ?] which
is his company, and
he's letting them
know that he'll be leaving
to pursue, basically,
the killer of his daughter--
the man that's been accused--
is wrongfully accused.
And that's where we
are introduced to him.
And it's an incredibly--
I'll let Richard jump
in, and then we'll
talk about the
premise, or whatever.
RICHARD T. JONES: I play
Detective Tommy Cavanaugh.
I'm an old-school cop.
I believe in the old-school
method of hard work and labor
is the way you solve crimes.
We're introduced, early
on in our relationship,
because I investigate--
I was one of the detectives
on the case for his daughter's
murder.
And Jeffery-- we disagree
on who we put in jail.
So we come-- yeah, what, 180?
That's how we start the show.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Had you guys
worked together before?
JEREMY PIVEN: No.
RICHARD T. JONES: No.
JEREMY PIVEN: Never had.
SPEAKER 1: So the
important question
is, did you Google
each other before you
started working together?
RICHARD T. JONES: I
watched "Entourage," so--
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICHARD T. JONES: No, I've
loved Jeremy since back
in "Say Anything" days, so--
JEREMY PIVEN: There you go.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah, man.
I know all your work.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah, and I've--
RICHARD T. JONES: Lucas.
JEREMY PIVEN: Oh my god.
Yeah-- go way back.
Still in high school.
No, and I've seen Richard--
he's been doing this thing
for as long as I have.
And it's great to work with--
Richard's amazing
and doing his thing,
and it's really fun
for us to work together
on many different levels.
And I think, also, just the fact
that his character is so old
school and hasn't necessarily
embraced technology--
and certainly not in this way--
and I think that our ideologies
are so completely different.
And the reality is is that
the police would, indeed,
be leery of a crowdsourced
crime-solving site,
because it could lead
to vigilante behavior
or we don't even know.
So I think that it's a really--
it's a great premise that
could absolutely exist today.
SPEAKER 1: I do appreciate
your character--
the voice of reason.
Because as someone who
works at a tech company,
it could be like that.
But we do have people
who try and dial it back
when things are on
the verge of insanity.
But I'm curious as to--
how familiar were you with the
Silicon Valley, Bay Area scene
before you signed on to this?
RICHARD T. JONES:
I watched a movie.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
Steve Jobs.
RICHARD T. JONES:
Yeah, Steve Jobs.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah, I mean--
RICHARD T. JONES:
That's about it, for me.
SPEAKER 1: Different company.
RICHARD T. JONES: But I
saw the Google movie, too.
SPEAKER 1: There we go.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah,
there's so much information
available to us
now, because it's
moving at the speed of
light, and it's important.
And I'm a bit of
a caveman myself,
just in terms of technology.
So it's fun to learn
about all this.
And I don't know
the numbers, but I
think probably
this and anti-aging
are the fastest-growing
markets in the world, probably.
RICHARD T. JONES: Wow.
JEREMY PIVEN: Or
anti-aging on Google.
RICHARD T. JONES: Or Google!
JEREMY PIVEN: Put
them both together.
SPEAKER 1: Slowly
merging into one Super.
JEREMY PIVEN: Exactly.
SPEAKER 1: So would you say that
technology doesn't play, like,
a large role in either
of your personal lives?
RICHARD T. JONES:
I would say that.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah?
RICHARD T. JONES: I
think Jeremy's role--
I think technology plays
a bigger role in his life
than mine.
I'm such a caveman.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
I am, too.
And it's just from, you know,
just not having to rely on it.
And then when you do, you
know, because it's all
about logging the hours--
and we haven't.
So we look like dummies
trying to figure stuff out.
SPEAKER 1: Does that make it--
RICHARD T. JONES: I have
a hard time with my phone.
SPEAKER 1: Does that make
it more challenging, though?
Because obviously,
you have to learn
this kind of, like, you
know, different language
that we tend to speak up here?
And you don't have to!
RICHARD T. JONES: Not from me!
So I'm kind of
learning the process.
JEREMY PIVEN: He just
has to look perplexed.
RICHARD T. JONES: Which is true.
It's the--
SPEAKER 1: Method acting.
RICHARD T. JONES:
--easiest job for me.
JEREMY PIVEN: It's true.
No, but for me, yeah,
it's been really
fun to learn this new
language, and to study it,
because it is a really
interesting mix of having
both sides of your brain
work at the same time,
because it is indeed technology.
But it's also artistic.
So you know, that's
really exciting to me.
And you know, it's about time
that I embrace it, anyway.
So I'm loving the journey.
SPEAKER 1: What do you think
the biggest change that you've
embraced has been?
JEREMY PIVEN: Oh,
that's a great question.
I don't know, just not
having a fear of it,
you know, because it can
be very intimidating.
You know, when I--
like, my mother, like,
she's even worse than I am.
Like, she doesn't know
how to use call waiting.
I mean, that's where my mom is.
She panics.
She just, like, will give
up if there's another call.
She just kind of throws the
phone away, and just gives up.
So I can help her,
and so that's great.
Yeah.
It's mostly just kind of, like,
not being intimidated by it,
and making friends
with it, embracing it.
Because it is the future.
The thing that
scares me, though,
is the whole AI aspect of it.
I mean, like, why
are we developing
artificial intelligence?
We haven't even developed
our own intelligence,
and, you know I mean?
You know, and, like, we have
so many other things to solve,
you know?
RICHARD T. JONES: And I have
so many people smarter than me.
I don't need, like, a computer
being smarter than me.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
RICHARD T. JONES: I
look at my computer
and I'm like, my
goodness, you're a genius.
JEREMY PIVEN: And that's
not going to end well.
You know what I mean?
How could that
possibly end well?
We're going to just figure
out a way for these machines
to think for themselves.
RICHARD T. JONES: Right.
JEREMY PIVEN: OK, great.
RICHARD T. JONES:
Terminator, for real.
JEREMY PIVEN: Right.
I mean--
SPEAKER 1: Heard it here.
Thanks so much.
Enjoy your time.
RICHARD T. JONES: But
you're doing great work.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Nobody worry.
We're all good.
But it is one of those
interesting things
that I think we grapple
with here, and I'm sure,
you know, the show runners
and writers grapple with.
And it kind of trickles
down to being issues
that you guys face.
And so, are there particular--
aside from AI, maybe,
things that, you know, the
show is covering that suddenly,
you're finding yourself doing
more research into, and being
like, wait, what's
that, or like,
what's the application of this?
Or is it more of a, I don't want
to know, I don't want to know?
RICHARD T. JONES: For me, it's
more of just really starting
to get into social media.
I really suck at
the whole thing.
And I have four kids, so I
spend so much time with them
that I have a hard time
doing what they do,
because they're so good at it.
So now, I'm starting to learn
what social media really does.
A little bit.
He's laughing.
So I'm starting to learn
how it really functions,
and how information is
dispersed through social media
at such a high level.
I just-- it still kind of
amazes me how it does it.
And so much of it is luck.
I mean, what blows
up and what doesn't.
And the timing of it, and
all that kind of stuff,
is amazing to me,
because I think
there have been a
lot of great ideas
that haven't taken off, because
they were before their time,
or there are many
other variables.
So, you know, from
a business aspect,
I think it's also
kind of fascinating.
SPEAKER 1: So not being,
like, super involved
in it before this,
what makes you want
to sign on to a show like this?
JEREMY PIVEN: Because it's
so prevalent and current.
And I'd like to
hear from you guys,
but I think that a site,
like a platform like this,
could exist.
And it probably already does--
it probably does, right?
RICHARD T. JONES: It does.
It does.
JEREMY PIVEN: You
know, and that's
why people are gravitating
towards this, because it's
completely plausible.
RICHARD T. JONES: Right.
JEREMY PIVEN: And, you know,
there's an argument to be made
on both sides, you
know, that you could--
the whole crowd-sourcing
idea that, you know, I mean,
90% of it you can't use,
and you pull from 10% of it,
and you know--
but we're living by
committee, anyway,
any time you look
up a restaurant,
or try to figure out the best
way to travel to a place,
you know, so--
RICHARD T. JONES:
That's a good point.
JEREMY PIVEN: --I
mean, we're already
very much using all that stuff.
And the human aspect of it--
I'd like to play a human being.
That's exciting to me, you know,
that actually has feelings.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah, the
characters are really rich--
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
RICHARD T. JONES: --also in it.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah
SPEAKER 1: What do
you think you admire
most about your characters?
JEREMY PIVEN: You
know, it's funny.
My character is
broken, and he's--
and he thinks-- he
believes that if he
finds the killer, that his
grief and his pain will go away.
And of course,
that's not the case.
And I think it's just
a very fertile premise,
because it can lead to any
type of behavior on his part.
And it's kind of dangerous.
And he's, you know,
emotionally available.
And we were developing this
great friendship, you know,
even though you
wouldn't see it coming.
And we have a lot of really
good, rich characters
that are surrounding us-- we
were just talking about this--
that, like, everyone's
really great on the show.
And so, you could go into
any one of their stories
at any time.
And also, we're trying to do
something that really hasn't--
outside of "The
Good Wife," I can't
think of another case
in which you've had
a real hybrid like our show.
It's not a procedural.
I have this throughline about
trying to find Mia's killer.
And yet, the platform is opening
us up to solving other cases.
And I've made a deal
with the cops that,
if they give me information--
oh, I can't-- well--
RICHARD T. JONES:
Yeah, you're on--
JEREMY PIVEN: I'm going--
I'm going to tell you
too much information.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah,
that's Episode 4, Episode 5!
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
All right.
I have to stop talking.
I haven't slept so I would
have started confessing things.
It's going to be weird.
Awkward.
RICHARD T. JONES: All right.
Just so you know.
SPEAKER 1: So I noticed--I think
one of the things I love is
that, Jeremy, you realize that
Tanner's more dressed up than,
like, any Silicon
Valley CEO, right?
Did you not make
the case for, like,
sweat pants and a black
t-shirt for your wardrobe?
RICHARD T. JONES: Actually,
I did, for my character.
SPEAKER 1: You did?
RICHARD T. JONES:
I would love that.
JEREMY PIVEN: Well, I
mean, it's interesting.
I mean, you've got
everyone from, you know,
the classics like
Steve Jobs, or like,
Fassbender-- all
he had to do was
put on those dad jeans
and a turtleneck.
And it was like, somebody
nominate this guy.
It's genius.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah, I mean-- but then you have
the Elon Musks of the world.
And, you know, he
puts it together well.
And so it's a little
bit all over the place.
And you have to
understand, he was
a guy who was
running his platform
and was wearing suits and
doing that whole thing.
And now, he's totally
driven and very casual.
So you'll see that
kind of journey.
He becomes more
casual as it goes on,
not caring what he looks like,
and being totally focused.
SPEAKER 1: We know
nothing about that here.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
Everyone looks very comfortable.
That's good.
SPEAKER 1: Did you sort
of look to the kind
of titans of this industry
for your performance?
Or was it something that you
sort of looked within yourself
to shape?
JEREMY PIVEN: Well, you've
got a guy, like I said,
who's pretty broken.
And this isn't modeled
after a specific person,
like if I was playing
the Elon Musk story,
then, you know, then that's
something very specific.
But he's an original creation.
So you can look at the Steve
Jobs of the world, who really
believe that the
variable to his success
was not limiting his thinking,
and being incredibly creative,
and not fearing other people,
their judgment about his ideas,
and being able to take
all these chances.
So I would look at guys like
that and go, OK, that's cool.
And then you help figure
out who that guy is.
He's been able to
walk into rooms
and dominate, and
blah, blah, blah.
But that's where
I'm coming from.
And now, I'm broken.
So it's kind of,
as an actor, it's
fun to play all of those
things, and then, you know,
hopefully try to
make it original.
SPEAKER 1: Richard, did
you ask to go on any police
ride-alongs, or did you
do these kind of hands-on,
where he's like, I'm just
going to wear dress-up pants?
RICHARD T. JONES: What's funny
is that I've played so many law
enforcement characters that--
I've done so many ride-alongs,
it's kind of like, OK, I'm--
SPEAKER 1: You're good.
JEREMY PIVEN: You're over it.
RICHARD T. JONES: I'm good.
I'm good.
But, you know, I have
a lot of officers
that are friends of mine.
So I just talk to them and try
to get in the headspace of, OK,
how would you embrace somebody
who knows nothing about law
enforcement, who knows--
but thinks he has a platform
to help you solve cases?
He's like, we go through
that all the time.
Everybody is a cop.
And so they have a
little resentment.
But they also need them, because
they do have information.
That's the only way.
It's the same--
crowd-sourcing happens.
It's just they like
to see people's faces.
They like to hear from them,
and not through the media.
JEREMY PIVEN: I think,
in a weird way--
I think the cops hate
that they need technology.
RICHARD T. JONES: Right.
JEREMY PIVEN: And I think
there are some civilians that
hate that they need cops.
An interesting duality.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah.
And you witness
that on the show.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah, exactly.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: I think
a lot of us probably
feel we could be less dependent
on technology, you know.
It's certainly a crutch for--
RICHARD T. JONES: Whoa, hold on.
That's what you guys feel like?
SPEAKER 1: I'm speaking
for myself, maybe!
RICHARD T. JONES: Oh!
SPEAKER 1: But, you know,
in my everyday life, there
were times when it's like,
I wish I could disconnect.
I wish I didn't need
my phone near me,
or something like that.
JEREMY PIVEN: Well, but,
I mean, think about it.
Think about how tied
we are to our phones.
RICHARD T. JONES:
Oh, my goodness.
JEREMY PIVEN: You know, we
look to it for validation,
to guide us to
where we're going,
to connect us with people.
And I know I remember
that, you know--
they've done this
research, and I
don't know the exact
amount of time it takes,
but you rarely find
anyone that can
go more than five minutes
without checking their phone,
you know?
And then these people check
the algorithms of all that,
and how to keep, like,
giving them little prizes,
you know, and suck
them in, you know?
And it's crazy.
It's psychological
warfare, at this point.
SPEAKER 1: You said that.
Not me.
JEREMY PIVEN: You
are evil people.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Switching
gears a little bit.
JEREMY PIVEN: OK.
SPEAKER 1: Do either of you
have any hidden talents?
RICHARD T. JONES: Uh-oh.
JEREMY PIVEN: I mean, I
don't know how hidden it is,
but I play the drums.
And I'm learning
how to tap dance.
Yeah, I play the drums.
I've played drums since
I was eight years old.
Yeah.
RICHARD T. JONES: I didn't--
it was hidden from me!
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah, exactly.
RICHARD T. JONES: I
see you every day!
JEREMY PIVEN: No, I love it.
I mean, there's no
drum kit on set.
Otherwise, I'd be on
that thing day and night.
RICHARD T. JONES: Why not?
You should put
one in the office.
JEREMY PIVEN: It's
actually not a bad idea.
No, I love to play the drums.
And that's definitely what
I would have been doing.
And I have a band, and
we play when we can.
And it's fun.
I've played some fun events.
I played one of Manny
Pacquiao's victory parties.
But no one told us that
the entire audience was
flown in from the Philippines.
And they were-- no
one told us that.
And all they wanted was, you
know, they're very into karaoke
in the Philippines.
And we were playing,
like, you know--
RICHARD T. JONES:
I can imagine this.
JEREMY PIVEN: --not
soft, you know--
we weren't "musacians,"
if you will.
And so, at the
end of every song,
it looked like a
Filipino oil painting.
They were just frozen.
And there was no response.
So it was a disaster.
And then Manny got out there.
And they went bananas.
And he was singing,
(SINGING IN NASAL VOICE)
"Sometimes, when we touch,
the honesty's too much."
Like that.
And I can't sing, either.
Bless him.
But they were going crazy--
crazy.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Enough of that.
RICHARD T. JONES: He's also
dabbling in-- what else?
JEREMY PIVEN: A
little tap dancing.
I can't--
RICHARD T. JONES: And?
Stand-up--
JEREMY PIVEN: Oh,
stand up comedy.
You came-- Richard
came to see me.
He was--
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah, he came to
see me do some stand up comedy
the other night.
RICHARD T. JONES: That--I know.
SPEAKER 1: Very
nice and supportive.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah,
he was supportive.
Yeah.
RICHARD T. JONES:
And he's funny.
He is--
JEREMY PIVEN: You
were surprised.
RICHARD T. JONES:
I was surprised.
I'm not going to lie.
I came out like, [INAUDIBLE],,
he's kind of good.
I was very, very surprised.
And he's very, very good.
JEREMY PIVEN: I had a blast.
It's like anything else.
I have a huge respect for it,
and I've been studying it.
And I think those
guys are incredible,
that they could just get
up there by themselves
and transform the space.
And I grew up doing
improv and whatnot.
But, you know,
stand-up is different.
And so, I've just been getting
up there and having fun.
SPEAKER 1: Dabbling?
JEREMY PIVEN:
Dabbling, if you will.
RICHARD T. JONES: I
play video games, and--
yeah.
JEREMY PIVEN: Is that a talent?
RICHARD T. JONES: It is for me.
Yeah, I have-- wow.
My life is-- I know how
to drive kids around.
SPEAKER 1: That's a talent.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: Multitasking,
scheduling.
RICHARD T. JONES: Thank you.
I didn't say that part.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
RICHARD T. JONES: I don't
know how to schedule.
But my talents are very limited.
Sorry.
SPEAKER 1: To build off--
RICHARD T. JONES:
(WHISPERING) Sorry.
SPEAKER 1: To build off that
last point, do either of you
have a go to karaoke song?
RICHARD T. JONES: Oh.
JEREMY PIVEN: You
know, I'm not--
RICHARD T. JONES: I do rap.
JEREMY PIVEN:
Yeah, it's easiest.
RICHARD T. JONES: Karaoke rap.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah?
RICHARD T. JONES:
That's why I do it.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
It's so easy. (RAPPING) 5:46
in the morning, crack of dawn
and now, I'm yawning.
Wipe the cold from my eyes--
RICHARD T. JONES: Oh.
SPEAKER 1: He's multi-talented!
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah.
Look at that [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 1: You're
really showcasing today!
RICHARD T. JONES: [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY PIVEN I'm
really old school.
SPEAKER 1: What inspires you?
JEREMY PIVEN: Just sunsets,
long walks, Chinese food,
black-and-white movies,
holding hands, gratitude--
RICHARD T. JONES: Good movies.
JEREMY PIVEN: --just
hashtag blessed.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: See, you've got
the internet thing down pat.
You've got it down pat.
RICHARD T. JONES: That
actually is my hashtag.
JEREMY PIVEN: There you go.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah.
Oh, my god.
Sorry, what was the question?
SPEAKER 1: It doesn't
matter anymore.
JEREMY PIVEN: What inspires us?
SPEAKER 1: What inspires you?
JEREMY PIVEN: --inspires us?
RICHARD T. JONES: Mountaintops.
I actually do like mountains.
See, I like nature.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
RICHARD T. JONES:
Making fun of me.
I like the strength that it--
SPEAKER 1: --embodies?
RICHARD T. JONES: That's right.
And That's why I like mountains.
Big mountains.
JEREMY PIVEN: Oh, yeah?
SPEAKER 1: What frustrates you?
RICHARD T. JONES: Long hours.
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY PIVEN: I just--
when people-- I
love collaborating.
And when people aren't into
collaboration, or at least
attempting to--
when they feel like their
way is the only way,
you know, I just like to have my
day in court, and just to kind
of, like, when you're
being creative,
just throw stuff in there, and
then whatever is, you know,
the best idea wins.
And that should
always be the case,
no matter where it comes from.
And when people are kind of
limited in their thinking,
that's a problem with me.
RICHARD T. JONES: It is.
SPEAKER 1: You've led into
my next question, which is,
living or dead, who is someone
you'd like to collaborate with?
RICHARD T. JONES: Wow, you're--
JEREMY PIVEN: Now, these
are really good questions.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah.
JEREMY PIVEN: You went
from nothing to everything.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you!
I tried to save it.
RICHARD T. JONES:
Living or dead?
SPEAKER 1: Living or dead.
RICHARD T. JONES: Ooh.
JEREMY PIVEN: I
think someone like--
I mean, Stanley Kubrick,
who's no longer alive,
is a genius, obviously.
Charlie Chaplin, Marlin
Brando, Carrot Top.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD T. JONES:
Carrot Top was a genius.
Why are you all laughing?
SPEAKER 1: Was?
What do you mean, was?
JEREMY PIVEN: He's in
Vegas right now, man.
He's still around.
RICHARD T. JONES: He is?
JEREMY PIVEN: Yes.
RICHARD T. JONES: Damn.
I thought he'd passed away.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah,
he's playing tonight.
We can go catch him.
SPEAKER 1: We're going to take
a few quick audience questions.
If anyone wants to head
back to the microphone.
And in the interim, what's one
of the best pieces of advice
you've been given?
JEREMY PIVEN: Best
pieces of advice.
Recently--
RICHARD T. JONES: You
[INAUDIBLE] some good advice?
JEREMY PIVEN: Yes.
I was about to go on
stage to do some stand-up.
And Kevin Nealon, who is just
a great old-school brilliant
stand-up, just said, you
know, take your time.
Breathe.
And let the audience
come to you, you know,
because, you know,
I'm so excited,
I want to bring it to them,
show them I got it, you know.
And it's like, no,
let them come to you.
And it just-- you
saw, it worked.
It really worked.
RICHARD T. JONES: Oh,
was it that night?
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
RICHARD T. JONES: It worked.
JEREMY PIVEN: It works.
It totally works.
That was a really
nice piece of advice.
RICHARD T. JONES: You know,
I'm a very big Christian,
so the advice I was given
a long time ago was,
always be passionate
about Jesus,
and understand that your
profession, which is acting,
that it shouldn't
be your passion.
It should be your profession.
But you're always passionate
about who you work for,
because I work for him.
So that got deep on you, see.
JEREMY PIVEN: Matt--
SPEAKER 1: Multi-layered.
JEREMY PIVEN: And he's
working with a Jew.
Imagine that.
RICHARD T. JONES:
That's my favorite part.
JEREMY PIVEN: But, you know,
Jesus was a Jew, so we're all--
RICHARD T. JONES: You know,
the Holy Day is coming up.
Yeah, see, look at--
SPEAKER 1: Tomorrow.
It's tomorrow.
RICHARD T. JONES:
Yeah, it's tomorrow.
JEREMY PIVEN: That's right.
There you go.
AUDIENCE: I got a little
double-part question.
The first part is, there
was another show that
came out last year called "APb"
with Justin Kirk and Eddie
Hudson.
Very similar, tech giant,
inventor, has an app,
solves crimes, avenging
his loved one who died--
RICHARD T. JONES: Never saw it.
AUDIENCE: Never saw it.
RICHARD T. JONES: Nope.
AUDIENCE: Anyway, any
similarity between that show
and your show?
And do you guys film
in San Francisco,
or just pretend to
film in San Francisco?
RICHARD T. JONES: I'll
take the second part first.
AUDIENCE: Second part first.
RICHARD T. JONES: We pretend
to film in San Francisco!
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
And Oakland.
No.
Yeah, we-- two very
leading questions,
and I appreciate that,
because I love a challenge.
I've never seen
or heard of "APB."
But I bless them
because, listen man,
you know, any time you do
a show, it's difficult.
Like, we were up
against 30 other pilots
at CBS when we got
lucky and we got picked.
Now, we're on Sunday
nights after "60 Minutes."
And Oprah is joining
"60 Minutes."
So-- that's crazy.
So "APB"-- someone
should put an APB out
on "APB," because
it's no longer around.
RICHARD T. JONES: --because we
actually do get this question.
But we actually
never saw the show.
AUDIENCE: It could
have been canceled.
I don't know.
RICHARD T. JONES: Oh,
did it get canceled?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I saw it last year.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
I don't-- I the
rumor is it's not--
SPEAKER 1: There's
a search engine
you can use to look
up the answer to this.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yes!
RICHARD T. JONES: But anyone
who is upset about that,
they can just tune
into our show,
because I think it's going
to be a little more--
AUDIENCE: Good solution.
JEREMY PIVEN: I think
that was something
about, he literally took over
a police station himself.
AUDIENCE: Correct.
JEREMY PIVEN: So, I mean, it
was technologically-driven.
But they're
completely different.
And this whole relationship--
it's a whole other show.
There will be no copyright
infringement enforced, at all.
And we shoot in LA.
And it takes place in San
Francisco and Oakland.
And we shot the
pilot in Vancouver,
and, you know, that's
the way it goes.
I'd love to shoot here.
It's amazing.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah.
JEREMY PIVEN: It's incredible.
RICHARD T. JONES: I think
you guys are too expensive.
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We hope you're on
for another 10 years solid,
and it becomes one
of those great shows.
JEREMY PIVEN: Thank you, sir.
RICHARD T. JONES:
Well, thank you.
JEREMY PIVEN: I appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: So how do you--
do you see the show as a
vehicle to explore, like,
sort of the
relationship between two
characters and the
technology piece, right?
Because your character
plays someone
who represents a large
portion of, you know,
CBS, of regular viewers
in the United States.
And your character represents
sort of this area and, like,
the embrace of technology.
How do you see that playing out
through the rest of the show?
JEREMY PIVEN: It's
a great question.
And I think that's part of this
incredibly fertile premise,
because he's completely
on the fence about--
you know, because--
RICHARD T. JONES: Completely.
JEREMY PIVEN: --yeah.
Because this is the
Wild, Wild, West,
you know, technology to him.
And he doesn't understand it.
And yet, there's so much
access to so much information.
And so, I think that
it would be great--
and I don't want to-- this
would be great if Ted was here,
our creator, and I'm going
to have to just speak--
I won't speak for him.
I'll speak for myself,
because that's all I can do--
I hope that we explore all the
dangers that it could present.
You know what I mean?
Because between my character,
who I think is obsessed with
finding his killer-- and that
can lead to some interesting
behavior--
and so that premise alone,
like, we're, you know,
becoming friends where, in the
beginning, we weren't at all,
you know?
But I value the way--
he's a straight shooter.
And I could tell he's
a real human being that
would be accessible to
doing the right thing.
So, you know, to answer that
question, I think that's--
listen, vigilante
behavior is already--
you know, it's already happened.
We see it all the time.
And so, it could lead to that.
And it already has led
to solving some cases.
So I think it can go either way.
It's a very fertile premise.
RICHARD T. JONES: But, yeah,
to bridge those two gaps,
I think that ultimately, it
would be a desired outcome from
[INAUDIBLE], I would think.
Like we said, we can't really
speak for the creator, but--
JEREMY PIVEN: But it's
also really scary,
because in the pilot,
you see it being
used for the highest purpose.
RICHARD T. JONES: Right.
JEREMY PIVEN: And
there are the--
you know, celebrities
are under surveillance.
That's what it is.
I mean, call it what it is.
You know, TMZs of the
world are hunting you
down for their own
profit and gain.
And now, we're talking
about people doing it
for the right reasons.
And that's pretty cool, I think.
And as you can see in
the pilot, everyone
is kind of following
this sexual predator.
And they bring him
down, all of them,
by, you know, videotaping
him, and everyone kind
of crowds around him.
And I think it's
exhilarating and also scary.
So I think that could
make for some good TV.
SPEAKER 1: I do think one
of the important parts,
though, is that it also broaches
the topic of, like, what
happens when that goes wrong?
What happens when that's
misused, you know?
RICHARD T. JONES: That's right.
JEREMY PIVEN: Right.
SPEAKER 1: We have to realize
there are consequences
to actions, you know--
RICHARD T. JONES: That's right.
JEREMY PIVEN: Absolutely.
SPEAKER 1: --vigilante actions!
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah, it's--
and then--
RICHARD T. JONES: We're also
putting other people in danger,
if people do it the wrong way.
So it's complicated.
AUDIENCE: What Comedy
Store did you go up at?
JEREMY PIVEN: At the Improv--
you saw me at the Improv.
And I do Laugh
Factory Comedy Store.
And I get-- I just
throw myself up there
in the middle of, you
know, like, you know,
seasoned professionals.
RICHARD T. JONES: Like,
seasoned professionals!
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
RICHARD T. JONES: He was, like,
in between, like, seasoned--
I was like, oh, no,
Jeremy, don't do this!
JEREMY PIVEN: Yeah.
RICHARD T. JONES: That's
why I was nervous for him,
'cause, like, wait--
like, Dane Cook's up here--
like, a lot of the big stars
are up here.
You're like--
JEREMY PIVEN: Joe Rogan, and
all these guys that really
have just honed their
craft, and they're
really great at what
they-- and I just
figured, if I could
put myself in that mix,
and I can still kind of survive,
then I might be all right.
But also, I love the
stakes of all that.
And so, it's just been a
real learning experience.
And I just got to keep
logging the hours.
So I'm having a really great
time, and I took it seriously.
And that's the only way you
could survive, in an arena
like that.
Like, you can't just get up
there and wing it, you know?
SPEAKER 1: All right.
So I think we have time
for a last question, which
is, if you could go back and
tell your younger self one
thing, what would it be?
JEREMY PIVEN: Wow, now we're
getting really deep, huh?
Wow.
RICHARD T. JONES: You
couldn't have briefed us--
SPEAKER 1: Do you want
me to lead with that?
RICHARD T. JONES: You
couldn't have briefed us--
JEREMY PIVEN:
Yeah, we could have
prepared for these questions.
RICHARD T. JONES: If I could go
back and tell my younger self--
JEREMY PIVEN: You
know, it's weird,
because I was such
a class clown.
And it somehow
paid off, you know?
It's weird.
I would have just-- it's like,
there's a part of me that
goes--
you know, because
one of my teachers,
you know, in high school,
was just like, you know,
(ACCENT) Jeremy, if you don't
straighten up and fly right,
you would be nothing!
You know?
And it was a disaster.
I don't even know
what accent that was.
I was so random, and vague.
[LAUGHTER]
It was supposed to be Indian.
And it wasn't.
It was a disaster.
So, you know, I've
been on the stage
since I was a child, and loving
it and having a great time.
And, you know, there
were a lot of subjects
that I wasn't good at.
But, you know, just
in terms of, we
were talking about a little
bit of organization and stuff
like that, and I
really, you know, I wish
that I knew Spanish, you know.
I was terrible.
And now, you know, just being
able to communicate when
you travel, is, like,
you take that for granted
as you're growing up.
And it'd be so great
to be in these cultures
and actually be
communicating with people,
speaking Italian, whatever.
So in that way, I kind
of feel like a dummy.
Wah-wah-wah.
RICHARD T. JONES:
I would have told
myself to pay more attention
in math and science,
so I could have created
something like Google.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Now you create art.
RICHARD T. JONES: Yeah, I
would have been, like, hey,
if Google ever comes--
if you ever hear of a thing
called Google, invest.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, what do you have?
Sell it all.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Well, thank you both so much.
Congrats on the show.
JEREMY PIVEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, guys.
RICHARD T. JONES: Thank
you for watching, guys.
JEREMY PIVEN: Thank you.